26 días después de su lanzamiento al
espacio la NASA lo consiguió la cápsula
orión volvió a la tierra y amerizó en el
océano Pacífico cerrando el primer
capítulo de la operación artemis 1
desde la tranquilidad del espacio a las
aguas tranquilas del Pacífico el último
capítulo del viaje de la NASA a la luna
llega a su cierre orión de vuelta en la
tierra la hora oficial del amerizaje las
11:40 y 30 segundos
la nave no tripulada entró a la
atmósfera terrestre a más de 39
kilómetros por hora probando uno de los
objetivos del viaje que la cápsula podía
aguantar hasta 2.760 grados Celsius al
entrar en la atmósfera y chocar con las
moléculas de aire
junto al éxito imágenes memorables por
la ventana de orión una tierra cada vez
más grande y silencio abrumador ahora el
programa artemis sucesor de Apolo está
un poco más cerca de su objetivo volver
a llevar astronautas a la luna después
de 50 años
vamos a ir de vuelta a la luna artemis 1
una misión con la que muchos han llegado
a preguntarse Por qué volver a la Luna
si la NASA ya consiguió llegar hasta
allí pero lo cierto Es que artemis 1
artemis 2 y artemis 3 que será la misión
que llevará a cuatro astronautas a la
luna en 2025 va mucho más allá se espera
que los astronautas se acostumbren a
vivir en el espacio y desarrollan
ciencia y tecnología para un objetivo
mucho más grande poder enviar a los
primeros Humanos a marte Marte todavía
está muy lejos será sobre la década de
2030 yo ya estaré retirado pero creo que
ocurrirá el final de este primer vuelo
coincide con una fecha muy especial el
50 del alunizaje del Apolo 17 la última
vez que los astronautas de la NASA
caminaron por la luna y ahora un poco
más cerca de volver a hacerlo
[Música]